F
FOATEMENTS SHELD
CARE TO OFFER.
>> THANK YOUY MU,
PERIMETERF BREACHED
CAPITOL.
SA
14 ENGAGED IHAND
TE IOC
CAPI
LAWFULLECTORVOTES, AND REVSEESU
CUANUARY 5thMRLIY PROFESSEKNOWQ
DIFFERENT THAN WHAMOERICANS PEAI
N WASHINGT.
WELL, HE S T
IN
BASE TMI
APPEARS ATNNON HADUBVANCED KNOW
NTOLTHAR6t
MR.  IWAR ROOM
AT OY 6t
HE ALSO APARE DETAILED
KNOWLEDGGAINESIDENT'S EFFORT
LL
S STOL. WORDS OMA
E JA, THE VIOLENCET DAY
CLAIMS -- FROM ELECTION NIGHT
THROUGAR6tHAD WON THE ELECTION
E ARE ENTITLED MR. BANNON'S FIAN
RELENT.AS THEMAE
BANNON IS RENG TO PROVIDE
NO LEGAL RIGHT TO F THIS STN.E
IG T'S LAWFUL SO F, BANNON'SE I
THATP O INVOKE SOME FORM OF
ECPRIVILEGE SU RT TOPICS.
PRESIDP'MMUNICATIONSH  G OR
JANUAR6th.
NFORMABET TO AT ALL.
ABR UNQUALIED HERE I BASIS
IVR PRESIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS
MORE NOW, THERE IS NO
MANY OTHER TOPICS IDENTIFIED IN
MITTEE'SUB
R, WE HAVE NO
FO. BANNON'S FAILURECOMPLY.
E CORE
IMPOT
INVESTIGATION.THEY ARE IMPTALLN.
MR.  MR. T'S
PRWER,APPEARAL ONE T
THEY SUGGESTT S PERSONALLY INVON
TH ANDON OF Y  COMMITT W.
LET ME A FURTHERPACAN
AISTEST NATION ON THE FACE OF
CONSTIMERICA JUSTID OU
THATHAT HAPPN JANUARY NOWS IN YA
NG.U ALL KNOWO
EVIDENCE OF N
IENT TVETHE
YOU ALL KNOW THAT THE DOMINION T
CORRUPEIGN POWYOU KNOW THESE CL
YET,ORP
REPEDA
D  UUBLICANS
NOT TOIN 2022 D S  FOR
NAASMY THE FUNDAMENT QUESTIONS D
THEY MUST KN TRUTH
AL US WHO ARD ALS MUST TO
PREVENE DISMANTLIN T LAW, ANDO U
THANK YO M I YIELD. PSU NIC NOW.
CALLN A ON RECOMMENDTH THEUSE O
STEVEN K. BANNON IN CONTPTF USA
THE O IGh UNITED STATES
CAPITOL.
THE REPORT WASD IN
ADVANCE, AND PRINTED COPIES ARE
AI
>> RORRECOMMENDING TT E HOUSE O
S FIND
FOR REL  MPTF COSS
SUBPNAY ISSUED BY THE
SE TO E
THE AR
WILL BNSAD  THE REPORT
OPEN TO AMENDMENTS AT ANY TIME
I WIF
NOW AT THE DESK.K SHALRE
AMENDMEN  AND THE NATBS
THOMPSONF MISSISSIPPI.
>> WITHOUT ODMENT
WILL BE CONSIDER AS READ
CONSIDEREDASTE
PU OR AMENDMENT.LL MYSELF TO
LETT I WROTE ON OCBEATMRBANNON'E
COMMITTEE'S SUNATO TONIGHT'S.
WIT ION, IMY
OCTOBER 15th LETTER IN
RECORD AS  AS YESTERDAS
LETTERROM ROBE. COSTELLO, Y.
IN LIGHT OLION FRESIDENTRU IE S
MBIA DISTRICT YESTHOWEVER, THE N
LAT IS IMM
DEFIANCE OFURNA.
I  TT CLEAR INETTER TOCOSTELLO N
WITHOBJEL
LETTER IS IN THE RECTEERDAY ISSO
BANN AATG,
QUOTE, WE ARE NO
BASIS  CS REFUSAA DEPOSITION, E
QUOTE.
SAID,  BIDEN HASTHER
ALY DET AN N OF EVILEGE
E PUBLAN TOTFIEDWI R TECTS
WITHIN THE PUREWE SELECTTEE,UOTE
LL WTE
RE.IS AMENDMENT AND TBS UEPOR TS
NOT TO COMPLWI SUBPOENA.RE DEBE,
QUTI AGREEING TO THE
AMENDMENT AND THE NATUREA TE.
THY YEA.
THOSOPPOSE NO.
AN OF THE CHAI
YEAS HAVE IT AND AT AN .COGNIZE
EY, FOR A MOTION.
>> MR. CHAIRMAN, MOVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE FAVORABLO
THE USTHE'S RTUTIONG  HOUSEF
Y ISSUEDTHE CONTEMPT ONGRESSFOYA
SELECT C TE JANUARY-6th ATTACK
T MOTIO
YEAS HIT>> M R, SAY >> YEAPPED
RECORDED VOT A RECORDED VOTE IS.
>>NE.
>> LOFES.
>> M S
>> YEA.
R. SCHIF YILAR?
AR
>> MRSMUA.
>> YEA.
>> RRA
KI YEA.
>> M COT
RE.
>> I VOTE
L REPO.
VOTE
>> O VOTE,
THERE AR YEAS, ZERO NOES.
>> THE MOTION IS AGREED TO
>>R. CHAIRMAN,UR
L OFUL
THATEMBERS HAVE TWO LEN WHICH T
PPLEMENTAL OR ADDITIONAL VIEWS E
AUTHORED NECESSATECHNICAL ORINGH